vraiment de m'excuser pourtant je suis
allée vite
le directeur merci beaucoup voilà de
venir pour pour cette audition de
qui correspond à la poursuite de nos
travaux pour la commission d'enquête sur
la pénurie de médicaments et les choix
d'industrie pharmaceutique française
puisqu'on allié à la fois la question du
médicament y compris des médicaments
anciens avec la question de des
médicaments
issus l'innovation puisque les questions
de coûts entre aussi en ligne de compte
et qu'on voit bien que c'est
ces deux aspects de la prise en charge
thérapeutique sont liées
donc vous êtes accompagné de Madame
Hélène menace au directrice de la
politique des produits de santé de la
qualité des pratiques et des soins et
Monsieur François Bruno qui est adjoint
à la sous-directrice et Madame Chantal
Guillaume qui n'est
qui n'a pas pu venir très bien donc je
vous remercie beaucoup de votre présence
parmi nous donc en application du code
de la santé publique la Direction
générale de la santé et notamment chargé
de l'élaboration des objectifs et
priorité de la politique de santé
publique
et on peut dire que elle a été
mise à contribution et très largement
ces dernières années
pour les politiques relatives au droit
des personnes malades et des usagers du
système de santé également elle veille
en outre à la qualité il y a la sécurité
des soins des pratiques professionnelles
des recherches biomédicales comme des
produits de santé
dans ce cadre la DGS contribue à
garantir l'accès des passions aux
innovations thérapeutiques donc c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles nous
traitons de cette question et prépare
conjointement avec la Direction de la
Sécurité sociale les décisions
permettant leur prise en charge par
l'assurance maladie elle participe plus
largement à la définition de la
politique du médicament dont on dont on
voit depuis le début de nos auditions
assez institutionnelles que de pour
lesquels de multiples acteurs
institutionnels interviennent aussi la
DGS a-t-elle participé ces dernières
années à la préparation et au suivi des
principales mesures législatives prises
pour enrayer les difficultés croissantes
d'approvisionnement tels que
l'obligation faite aux industriels de
constituer des stocks de sécurité et
d'établir pour chacun des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutiques majeur qu'ils
exploitent un plan de gestion des
pénuries et notamment un système
d'alerte sur lequel on
réfléchissons également
qu'il avait été déjà préconisé il y a
quelques années et on voit que pour
certains certains produits
certains médicaments ils fonctionnent
imparfaitement la DGS a également
contribué à l'élaboration et au suivi de
la feuille de route 2019-2022 de lutte
contre les pénuries de médicaments c'est
pourquoi votre audition par la
commission d'enquête nous a paru
particulièrement importantes alors que
le nombre de médicaments ruptures ou en
tension ne cesse d'augmenter dans la
mission flash que nous avions effectué a
été 2018 il y avait à peu près 700
médicaments en pénurie réelle on a
triplé la mise on peut dire les choses
de cette façon c'est un peu trivial mais
c'est effectivement c'est la dure
réalité
et nous souhaiterions que vous puissiez
dresser dans une brève présentation
introductive un bilan des mesures prises
ces dernières années il y a un panorama
de la situation actuelle
en abordant à la fois les questions
structurelles mais aussi les questions
conjoncturelles puisqu'on sait que nous
vivons aussi une situation
de conjoncture sanitaire particulière
quels sont les principaux médicaments
touchés par les phénomènes de pénurie
pourquoi les mesures prises
s'avèrent-elles insuffisantes pour
enrayer ces difficultés comment
peuvent-elles être renforcés qu'elles
sont concrètement les conséquences de
ces difficultés sur la prise en charge
des patients leurs conditions de vie et
leur pronostics je passerai ensuite donc
la parole à Laurence Corenne ma collègue
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
j'insiste sur le E je précise que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié et
avant de vous passer la parole Monsieur
le Directeur Général madame et monsieur
je vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête et
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal et je vous invite à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure
merci merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur Général vous avez la parole je
vous remercie beaucoup madame la
présidente Madame la rapporte heureux
Mesdames et Messieurs les
vice-présidentes et vice-présidents
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
les enjeux d'accès aux médicaments sont
cruciaux dans le monde et en Europe en
France ils sont au cœur des politiques
de santé publique et de sécurité
sanitaire de réponse aux besoins de la
population et des patients des attentes
des professionnels de santé des enjeux
de recherche et d'innovation mobilisant
l'ensemble des acteurs de la chaîne du
médicament des industriels jusqu'aux
personnes malades en passant par les
grossistes répartiteurs et les 21 000
officines présentes sur le territoire
national
l'anticipation et la prévention des
risques de pénurie de médicaments est
une priorité du ministère en charge de
la santé depuis plusieurs années qui est
évidemment suivi en temps réel il s'agit
donc d'un sujet majeur évolutif complexe
d'origine multifactorielle d'ampleur
internationales qui ne mobilise au
quotidien
permettez-moi d'avoir quelques rappels
la pénurie traduction de shortage en
anglais est un terme générique qui
n'apparaît dans le Code de Santé
publique que pour désigner les plans de
gestion de pénurie la tension
d'approvisionnement n'est pas définie en
tant que tel dans les textes et signifie
que les stocks sont disponibles mais que
les quantités sont insuffisantes pour
couvrir les besoins et cela peut donc
aboutir à une rupture nous distinguons
les ruptures de stock des ruptures
d'approvisionnement qui sont codifiées
et encadrés par les textes ainsi la
rupture d'approvisionnement est définie
dans le Code de Santé publique comme
l'incapacité pour une pharmacie
d'officine ou une pharmacie à usage
intérieur de dispenser un médicament à
un patient dans un délai de 72 heures
après avoir effectué une demande
d'approvisionnement auprès de deux
entreprises exerçant une activité de
distribution de médicaments ce délai de
72 heures peut être réduit à
l'initiative du pharmacien en fonction
de la compatibilité avec la poursuite
optimale du traitement
la rupture de stock est définie comme
l'impossibilité de fabriquer ou
d'exploiter un médicament et là aussi
dans le Code de Santé Publique article
51 R51 24
le sujet est complexe je vous l'ai dit
parce que les causes sont multiples et
sans citer l'ensemble des causes il y a
cinq grandes familles les défauts des
outils de production
le manque de matières premières et
d'articles de conditionnement la
capacité de production insuffisante ou
dans le même temps l'augmentation des
volumes des ventes des contrôles de
médicaments non conformes donc à la
suite en général d'inspection ou
d'autres motifs comme des modifications
d'AMM des arrêts de commercialisation ou
des enjeux logistiques donc on voit bien
des causes différentes qui appellent des
réponses adaptées que ce soit une
situation de monopole une production
dans un seul site une augmentation des
indications médicales de la taille des
populations traitées de nouveaux marchés
des besoins en fonction de d'enjeux
sanitaire par exemple des enjeux de
sécurité et de qualité et vous l'avez
rappelé madame la Présidente nous sommes
aussi responsables de la qualité du
médicament et de la sécurité sanitaire
des populations traitées
les risques de pénurie présentent par
ailleurs des facteurs conjoncturels une
demande et une consommation plus élevée
de médicaments pèse évidemment sur leur
disponibilité avec un exemple tout
récent celui de la pandémie de covid et
de ces derniers mois puisque nous avions
notamment un contexte triple épidémie à
contexte inédit de triple épidémie
bronchiolite avait RS grippe et
infections covid avec comme vous le
savez on pourra en reparler de très
fortes tensions sur l'amoxicilline en
antibiotique et sur le paracétamol la
antalgique antipyrétique
le phénomène n'est pas nouveau on
constate son accroissement lié à la fois
à des incitations au signalement et à
des tendances de fond à moyen terme
comme des marchés émergents comme des
crises internationales le nombre de
déclarations de rupture ou de risque de
rupture de stock de médicaments dit
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur les MITM
n'a cessé d'augmenter ces dernières
années et a été multiplié par 9 entre
2016 et 2022 les causes des pénuries
sont multifactériennes je l'ai déjà dit
elles sont principalement liées à la
mondialisation de la production de
médicaments qui entraîne une
fragmentation et une complexité accrue
de la chaîne de fabrication et
d'approvisionnement les hausses
significatives constatées à partir de
2019 s'explique en partie par la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui a
introduit introduit l'obligation pour
les industriels de signaler les risques
de rupture le plus en amont possible
mais également vous le savez aussi par
la pandémie de covid
qui a accentué les pénuries de
médicaments cette situation a été
aggravée en 2022 par la situation
géopolitique la crise énergétique et la
reprise de l'inflation
les risques de rupture et les ruptures
de stock touchent essentiellement des
médicaments commercialisés depuis
longtemps les médicaments matures
beaucoup moins les derniers médicaments
mis sur le marché
la NSM analyse et signalement et mettent
en oeuvre les mesures nécessaires pour
réduire l'impact de la tension nos
prévisionnement pour les patients ces
mesures vont jusqu'à l'importation de
médicaments similaire provenant d'autres
pays
parmi les signalements de rupture au
risque de rupture et les classes
thérapeutiques les plus touchées en 2022
était surtout les médicaments
intervenants sur le système
cardiovasculaire 29% du système nerveux
19% et les anti-infectieux 14%
. il s'agit d'un phénomène rencontré au
niveau international on donnerait deux
exemples que nos concitoyens connaissent
bien le paracétamol qui a fait l'objet
de tension d'approvisionnement depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois ces causes
reposent notamment sur l'augmentation de
la consommation avec les trois épidémies
saisonnières bronchiolite grippe covid
l'impact de la situation géopolitique
est également à prendre en compte en
particulier pour l'accès aux cartons et
à l'aluminium matière première
indispensable pour conditionner le
paracétamol et en 2022 c'est assez
frappant près de 10 millions de boîtes
de paracétamol pédiatriques
supplémentaires ont été vendus par
rapport à 2021 il y a une enquête du
pharmacist Stickle groupe of your open
union le pgue du 10 janvier 2023 qui
montre que la quasi-totalité des pays
européens connaissent des tensions avec
une situation particulière vous le savez
qui est que la France est le plus gros
consommateur de paracétamol parmi ces 5
pays
et donc devant le Royaume-Uni l'Espagne
l'Italie et l'Allemagne en ce qui
concerne l'amoxicilline qu'elle soit
seule ou en association avec l'acide
clavilanique donc un antibiotique
extrêmement fréquent là aussi de très
fortes tensions d'approvisionnement les
formes les plus impactées sont
principalement les suspensions buvables
en flacon qui sont majoritairement
prescrites en vide chez les enfants et
laboratoires expliquent ces tensions en
amoxicilline par l'augmentation très
importante de la consommation en
antibiotiques couplée à des difficultés
sur les lignes de production
industrielles lors de la pandémie c'est
important de le signaler la demande en
amoxicilline avait très fortement
diminué
conduisant à une réduction voire un
arrêt de certaines lignes de production
qui n'ont pas retrouvé leur capacité de
production d'avant la pandémie et là
encore l'enquête pgeu donc du groupe
pharmaceutique de l'Union européenne
montre que la quasi-totalité des pays
européens connaissent des tensions la
France vous le savez est le plus gros
consommateur d'antibiotiques et le plus
gros consommateur
d'amoxicilline parmi les cinq pays du
marché global et donc en particulier
pour les dosages des enfants on était
derrière donc enfin nous étions devant
le Royaume-Uni l'Espagne l'Allemagne et
enfin l'Italie donc un pays
particulièrement concerné par les enjeux
d'accès aux antibiotiques et ça me
m'incite à rappeler les enjeux cruciaux
de la lutte contre l'antibio résistance
qui vous savez constituent une des
menaces mondiales des 10 menaces
mondiales pour la santé publique selon
l'OMS et donc de rappeler l'importance à
nos concitoyens du bon usage des
antibiotiques
vous avez déjà entendu la Haute Autorité
de Santé et l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et donc ça peut
permettre de rappeler comment toutes ces
institutions sont mobilisées en France
dans la politique du médicament d'abord
parce que pour accéder au marché tout
candidat médicament doit d'abord obtenir
l'AMM donc l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché à la vue de critères d'efficacité
de tolérance avec cette fameuse balance
bénéficerie de qualité et de sécurité
favorable cette am peut être délivré par
la NSM ou par son homologue européen
l'Agence européenne des médicaments donc
yopen médecine agency par une procédure
dite centralisée ou de reconnaissance
mutuelle presque toutes les innovations
thérapeutiques font désormais l'objet
d'une procédure centralisée dans un
deuxième temps interviennent la décision
de prise en compte par l'Assurance
Maladie puis la fixation du prix du
médicament ayant préalable préalablement
obtenu son am et donc cette la Haute
Autorité de santé qui intervient
notamment sur l'évaluation du SMS et de
la SMR
par la Commission de transparence puis
nous avons l'évaluation économique et de
santé publique ce qu'on appelle l'avis
déficience qui est produit par la
Commission et d'évaluation économique
vous avez entendu ce matin le président
du comité économique des produits de
santé qui est un organisme
interministériel placé sous l'autorité
conjointe des ministres chargés de la
santé de la sécurité sociale et de
l'économie et qui est donc chargé par la
loi de fixer des prix des médicaments et
les tarifs de dispositif médicaux à
usage individuel pris en charge par
l'assurance maladie obligatoire avec ces
fameuses deux sections la section du
médicament et la section des dispositifs
médicaux la DGS siège au CEPS il y a une
voix parmi les autres membres du CEPS
évidemment l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament est l'agence sont
responsabilité sur la prévention des
pénuries de médicaments en mobilisant
tous les leviers à sa disposition
contingentement recherche de repreneurs
autorisation d'importation alternative
et la DGS
vous l'avez dit madame la Présidente est
évidemment au coeur des politiques de
santé publique de sécurité sanitaire de
bataille pour la qualité et de promotion
de l'innovation et de la recherche donc
tutelle de la NSM et impliqué dans tous
les domaines de la lutte contre les
ruptures de médicaments et elle
coordonne et anime la politique en
matière de lutte contre les pénuries de
médicaments en portant notamment le
cadre réglementaire dans le code de la
santé publique la coordination des
actions qui ont été progressivement
portées dans le cadre d'une feuille de
route pluie annuelle les situations
préoccupantes sont signalées par la NSM
et si besoin donc étudier en réunion
hebdomadaire de sécurité sanitaire qui
est présidé par le directeur général de
la santé
je l'ai rappelé cette situation
nécessite une mobilisation des autorités
depuis plusieurs années et en
particulier en France des actions fortes
sont portées depuis plus de 10 ans avec
un dispositif ambitieux je n'irai pas
dans les détails je voudrais vous
rappeler le dispositif juridique de 2012
avec le décret 2012 1096 qui met en
place des obligations très importantes
et très innovantes pour prévenir des
ruptures d'abord pour les exploitants je
cite l'obligation d'informations de la
NSM par les exploitants en cas de
rupture potentielle de médicaments
l'obligation d'approvisionner tous les
établissements autorisés au titre d'une
activité de grossiste répartiteur afin
de permettre de le respect des
obligations de services publics et de
manière à couvrir les besoins des
patients en France l'obligation de
mettre en place des centres d'appel
d'urgence et tout ça pour les
exploitants c'est aussi préciser les
stocks les modalités disponibilités les
délais de prévisionnels et
l'identification de spécialités de
substitution autre axe majeur les
grossistes répartiteurs qui vous savez
ont un territoire de répartition qui est
désormais soumis à autorisation de la
direction générale de la NSM donc là
encore compatible avec des obligations
de service public des obligations de
services publics qui sont d'ailleurs
renforcés je me permets de les rappeler
donc l'approvisionnement moins de 8h le
samedi à partir de 14h le dimanche et
les jours fériés la possession de 9/10
des présentations des spécialités
pharmaceutiques commercialisées en
France et les signalements obligatoires
des ruptures en médicaments à
l'exploitant ce dispositif juridique a
été renforcé en 2016 puisque cette année
là la France a élaboré des mesures de
prévention des ruptures pour d'une part
renforcer l'implication les obligations
et les responsabilités des acteurs de la
chaîne du médicament de l'entreprise
pharmaceutique jusqu'au pharmacie
d'officine et surtout définir la
supervision de ce système par la NSM
donc il y a l'article 151 de la loi du
26 janvier 2016 de modernisation de
notre système de santé la lmss qui a
introduit dans le Code de Santé publique
les dispositions relatives à la lutte
contre les ruptures d'approvisionnement
de médicaments et c'est ces fameuses
dispositions qui ont créé
la notion de médicament d'un intérêt
thérapeutique majeur et qui impose
notamment des obligations spécifiques
aux titulaires d'AMM et aux exploitants
de ces médicaments comme l'élaboration
et la mise en oeuvre des plans de
gestion des pénuries des PGP pour les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur donc qui sont soumis à la NSM
il y a eu des décrets par la suite donc
notamment en juillet 2016 qui ont permis
de
fixer les critères d'identification des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs et donc de ces médicaments qui
font l'objet d'un plan de gestion des
pénuries des arrêtés complémentaires ont
été publiées à l'été 2016 qui ont fixé
notamment la liste des vaccins et la
liste des classes thérapeutiques qui
contenaient des médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutiques majeur donc toutes ces
mesures ont été progressivement mises en
place depuis l'été 2016 et évidemment au
cours de l'année 2017 ensuite vous
l'avez cité madame la Présidente il y a
eu cette fameuse feuille de route pour
permettre de lutter contre les pénuries
d'améliorer la disponibilité des
médicaments en France la feuille de
route 2019-2022 28 actions en quatre
axes je vais pas vous citer toutes les
actions je vous rappelle juste les axes
promouvoir la transparence et la qualité
de l'information afin de rétablir la
confiance et la fluidité entre tous les
acteurs du professionnel de santé
jusqu'au patient la lutte contre les
pénuries médicaments par des nouvelles
actions de prévention et de gestion du
circuit des médicaments la coordination
national et la coopération européenne
pour mieux prévenir les pénuries et la
nouvelle gouvernance nationale les
associations de patients les acteurs de
la chaîne du médicament et les autorités
nationales compétentes se sont donc
réunis dans des groupes de travail pour
mettre en place des actions concrètes je
me permets de le souligner les actions
ont été engagées malgré la crise qui est
survenue en janvier 2020 donc une crise
évidemment mondiale sans précédent mais
surtout elles ont été enrichies avec des
solutions innovantes acquises pendant la
pandémie donc le renforcement des
dispositifs juridiques de prévention je
cite le remplacement des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur en
rupture c'est un dispositif qui
aujourd'hui opérationnel article 34 de
la Loi ots 2019 le renforcement de la
capacité de régulation de la NSM pour
lutter et anticiper les pénuries et
l'article 48 de la FSS 2020 avec ce
fameux stop de sécurité permanent que la
NSM vous a cité donc deux mois pour tous
les MITM et une semaine pour les autres
médicaments les dérogations à la hausse
et à la baisse des plans de gestion de
qui est un outil évidemment innovant en
France qui permet de sécuriser la chaîne
d'approvisionnement des principes actifs
et des produits finis puisque tout MITM
doit faire l'objet d'un PGP un PGP
déposé par spécialité avec des lignes
directrices de la NSM le renforcement
des sanctions en cas de non-respects des
obligations des industriels en matière
de lutte contre les ruptures que ce soit
le stock de sécurité ou le PGP est des
sanctions étaient prononcé en 2022 et
puis l'actualisation donc des lignes
directrices par la NSM avec la
détermination de sanctions financières
il y a eu des inspections en 2022 j'ai
pas le bilan définitif de l'année mais
il y a déjà plusieurs dizaines
d'inspections qui ont été réalisées et
notamment plusieurs dizaines
d'inspections qui ont donné lieu à des
écarts par rapport à la gestion de
pénurie deuxième grand axe la
transparence et l'information autour des
situations de rupture et là évidemment
c'est ce sujet majeur pour nous que
d'élargir et d'améliorer l'accès des
professionnels de santé aux plateformes
d'information sur les pénuries
pour la mise en place de solutions de
partage d'information j'insiste aussi
sur le sur le rôle notamment des
pharmaciens officines et de l'Ordre des
pharmaciens pendant la crise ça a été
vraiment des partenaires et des
partenaires extrêmement précieux donc un
exemple des perructures qui a été
développé par l'ordre mais aussi la
refonte complète du site internet de la
NSM l'objectif étant de le rendre de
plus lisible possible plus accessible
possible au grand public l'amélioration
de la gestion et la sécurisation de
l'ensemble de la chaîne du médicament ce
sont les tous les travaux qui ont été
engagés pour faire évoluer les modalités
d'achat par les établissements de santé
et enfin le grand l'axe 4 la
souveraineté sanitaire afin d'éviter les
pénuries en santé avec au niveau
national l'accord cadre 2021 2024 qui a
été signé entre les entreprises du
médicament et le CEPS et qui mobilisent
des leviers pour renforcer le
développement et la production de
médicaments sur le territoire dans le
souci de favoriser une souveraineté une
sécurité d'approvisionnement et vous le
savez dans le cadre de France relance de
nombreux dispositifs
côté favoriser pour développer des
productions en France depuis 2020
un travail de collaboration évidemment
entre plusieurs acteurs mais mis en
place en particulier par la Direction
Générale des Entreprises c'est pas
décisif vers une plus grande
souveraineté de la France et de l'Union
européenne et je voudrais citer
d'ailleurs au niveau européen un projet
majeur c'est le projet que vous
connaissez le projet dipiak projet
important d'intérêt européen commun qui
est un instrument juridique à la
disposition des États membres qui permet
de déroger sous certaines conditions aux
règles contraignant les aides d'État
afin de pouvoir financer directement les
entreprises donc en conclusion de
nombreux temps forts dès 2012 avec la
prévention les MITM en 2016 les plans de
gestion en 2017 la feuille de route en
2019 le décret stock en 2021 mais nous
avons voulu tirer toutes les leçons de
la crise majeure covid d'abord signaler
l'émergence des préparations
hospitalières spéciales les PHS lors de
la pandémie le réseau des pharmaciens
hospitaliers encore un grand hommage aux
pharmaciens l'établissement
pharmaceutique de l'Assistance publique
hôpitaux de Paris santé publique France
et la NSM ont été mobilisés par le
Ministère afin de permettre la
production en urgence de préparation de
six atracurium donc c'est un curare qui
est un rupture de stock un scalope a été
réalisé avec un sous-traitant privé pour
les besoins des patients sur les
territoires et c'est donc une preuve de
concept qui a été validée puisqu' avec
ce sisa très curium 50 mg il a été mis
en sur le marché en moins de trois mois
quatre lots de 200 000 ampoules en
juillet 2021 4 lots de 200 000 ampoules
en 2022 donc une expérience réussie
menée pendant la crise qui a été
pérennisé par l'article 61 de la LFSS
2022 un décret en Conseil d'État précise
les modalités de mise en œuvre se
décrets définit les conditions
d'autorisation temporaire des PHS pour
des établissements pharmaceutiques la
GEPS ou la Pharmacie centrale des armées
qui sont habilités à partir d'un cahier
des charges l'autorisation temporaire
est délivrée soit par la NSM soit par le
ministre de la santé c'est un texte en
cours de concertation qui devrait être
publié au second semestre autre solution
innovante
issue de la crise de partage
d'information
durant la crise donc de nombreuses
mesures de la feuille de route ont vu le
jour notamment la plateforme i dispose
stop de suivi de certains produits de
santé en PU qui permet la remontée de
ses stocks et une supervision à la fois
régionale par les agences régionales de
santé omédite et national et puis enfin
les premières actions de relocalisation
le plan de relance qui est engagé par le
gouvernement avec quatre piliers
améliorer notre compétitivité pour
localiser plus d'activité en France
faire de la transition écologique à
davantage comparatif moderniser notre
appareil de production et innover pour
nos positionner sur des marchés d'avenir
dans le cadre de ces nombreux
dispositifs les choix se sont portés
pour une relocalisation des médicaments
utiles dans la prise en charge des
patients atteints covid et la production
des vaccins contre la covid l'action de
sous-traitance donc ces actions
évidemment extrêmement importantes pour
la France elles sont un pas décisif vers
une plus grande souveraineté de la
France et de l'Union européenne et enfin
la logique européenne et vous saviez
combien la DGS est active dans ce champ
avec un enjeu qui est le renforcement de
la coopération européenne la pandémie a
permis l'émergence d'une Europe de la
santé avec le secteur de la santé était
un secteur régalien donc c'est un pas
important de l'Europe avec notamment le
renforcement du rôle de l'agence
ime donc de l'Agence européenne du
médicament mais aussi la création de
Héra qui est l'agence de réponse aux
crises de la Commission européenne qui
nous pousse donc à tirer les leçons de
cette crise sanitaire mondiale au niveau
de l'Europe la réponse aux pénurie de
médicament ne peut être uniquement
national la garantie de la disponibilité
des médicaments et des produits de est
en effet un axe majeur pour tous les
patients de l'Union européenne et dans
le cadre de la stratégie pharmaceutique
pour l'Europe on nous avons donc une
proposition de texte qui a été annoncée
par la commission au cours de ce
trimestre la France est au rendez-vous
et reste très impliqué sur ce chantier
afin de promouvoir les mesures
développées au niveau national
renforcement des obligations
d'approvisionnement de transparence le
PGP la cartographie européenne des
chaînes d'approvisionnement par exemple
donc ces textes sont actuellement en
relecture inter service et l'approbation
par les commissaires est prévue pour le
29 mars voilà Mesdames et Messieurs le
bilan de la mobilisation et des actions
menées en France depuis plus de 10 ans
pour anticiper et réduire l'impact des
tensions sur les médicaments est
important mais nous devons nous adapter
à un contexte particulièrement évolutif
nous tirons les leçons de la pandémie et
sommes pleinement mobilisées face aux
difficultés rencontrées pour mieux
anticiper
accroître encore notre réactivité
intégrer davantage la dimension
saisonnière ça a été évidemment très
frappant à l'automne disposé d'une
cartographie des risques sécuriser au
mieux les à Fort en jeu de santé
publique renforcer et approfondir la
feuille de route avec des solutions
préarmées et une cinétique d'action
efficace mieux informer et accompagner
les patients premier concerné et acteurs
clés évidemment et bien entendu
collaborer de façon efficace et en temps
réel avec tous les professionnels de
santé avec une attention toute
particulière pour les prescripteurs et
les pharmaciens nous préparer à gérer au
mieux les situations difficiles à venir
en renforçant la réponse européenne je
vous remercie de votre attention
évidemment je me tiens à votre
disposition pour toutes les questions
très bien merci beaucoup pour ce tour
très complet et cette remise en
perspective de toutes les décisions
d'évolution réglementaire et législative
je vais immédiatement passer la parole à
ma collègue rapporteur lance Cohen
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le directeur général de la Santé merci
pour vos explications qui étaient
effectivement extrêmement fournie et on
a vu votre mobilisation et celle de vos
services plané entières mais justement
compte tenu de toutes les mesures que
vous avez mises en avant comment vous
expliquer que la situation continue de
se de se dégrader
est-ce que il n'y a pas eu un manque
d'anticipation et notamment je pense
effectivement on nous a dit il y a trois
il y a eu la convergence de trois
risques importants c'est-à-dire
effectivement la covid bronchiolite et
grippe mais je veux dire c'est pas un
scoop pour pour le monde de la santé que
de voir effectivement ce genre de
d'affection hivernale on va dire alors
même si elles se sont arrivées
pratiquement au même moment est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'il y a eu un
manque d'anticipation et est-ce que
justement à partir du moment où on a vu
dans la presse énormément d'articles
concernant les pénuries alors les plus
emblématiques évidemment il s'agit vous
l'avez dit doliprane amoxicilline etc
est-ce que vous n'avez pas vous en amont
été saisi par des personnels de santé
qui se sont inquiétés je pense notamment
d'ailleurs au milieu hospitalier qui
avait vu un peu les choses arrivées qui
sentaient déjà que les les productions
internes à l'hôpital ferait feraient des
fautes donc est-ce que vous avez été
alerté en amont et si oui comment vous
avez pu ou pas
réagir
les pénuries touchent effectivement un
grand nombre d'air thérapeutiques et les
associations de patients ou la Ligue
contre le cancer font état de perte de
chances importantes est-ce que vous vous
pouvez mettre vous avez mis ou vous
mettez sur pied en fait un suivi des
conséquences sanitaires des pénuries
donc et sous quelle forme vous pouvez
mettre ce dispositif
et quel bilan sanitaire finalement vous
dressez des phénomènes de pénurie qui
sont constatés je parle pas des plus
récentes mais vous l'avez signalé ça
fait quand même une dizaine d'années
donc est-ce que vous avez une évaluation
de ces conséquences
les autres questions concernent plus le
moratoire sur les baisses des prix des
génériques stratégiques est-ce que vous
estimez que les prix des spécialités
matures soient véritablement trop bas
c'est quelque chose qui pour lesquels
nous sommes sensibles au niveau de la
commission d'enquête parce que d'un côté
on nous dit et vous vous l'avez dit
effectivement il y a pénurie par rapport
aux produits matures et pas sur les
innovants bon donc et on nous dit les
prix matures sont trop bas et c'est ce
qui explique en partie les difficultés
que l'on a est-ce que vous corroborez
cette cet élément d'analyse ou pas et en
plus en contrepartie il y a eu quand
même un engagement du gouvernement
contrepartie des hausses des prix les
industriels doivent s'engager à une
sécurisation de l'approvisionnement du
marché français et notamment
la comment là elle FSS pour 2022 permet
d'intégrer l'implantation industrielle
comme critère dans la négociation des
prix on en a eu une confirmation dans
notre précédente
audition donc cette mesure étant
d'application directe
comment est-ce que vous expliquez
qu'elle ne soit pas mise en oeuvre
encore et quels sont les raisons
pour lesquelles elles ne sont pas mises
en oeuvre enfin nous avons été alertés
sera ma deuxième question nous avons été
alertés sur la pénurie structurelle
structurelle d'un médicament qui est
bien particulier et qui est vital pour
les patients qui en ont besoin c'est le
plasma
et dont fait dans le cadre des
prélèvements effectués sous l'égide de
l'Établissement français du sang vous le
savez nous le savons tout et tous sont
nettement insuffisants pour faire face
aux besoins et
le LFB est un producteur français et à
ce titre français et public et à ce
titre il devrait être un acte de
satisfaire l'ensemble des besoins des
Françaises et des Français mais on voit
bien que malheureusement c'est assez
compliqué donc j'aimerais avoir votre
votre analyse là dessus et comment vous
entendez remédier à cette pénurie
finalement qui pèse lourdement sur la
qualité des soins qui sont prodigués aux
patients concernés je crois qu'ici nous
sommes nous partageons toutes et tous le
même le même point de vue c'est que nous
sommes vraiment très préoccupés par les
risques
que connaît le LFB et qui fait peser du
coup sur l'ensemble du système national
du don du sang et nous sommes très
attachés toutes et tous justement à ce
service public à ce don gratuit etc qui
est une particularité que l'on veut
défendre au niveau au niveau de notre
pays voilà
Monsieur le Directeur Général Monsieur
le Directeur
merci beaucoup ma présidente merci
Madame la rapporteur alors peut-être
commencer par préciser un point
important puisque on a cité le les deux
pénuries récentes qui ont été très
fortement médiatisées et de façon
légitime puisque c'était deux molécules
auxquelles nous concitoyens sont très
attachés l'amoxicilline n'est pas
estamol la situation s'est améliore donc
c'est important aussi de le dire elle
s'améliore nettement sur le front de
l'amoxicilline et elle est quasi
normalisée désormais sur le sur le front
de du paracétamol
là encore c'est assez frappant de le
dire d'emblée les habitudes de
prescription et les habitudes entre
guillemets de consommation même si je
n'aime pas ce terme pour un médicament
les Français sont attachés à un certain
nombre de molécules et donc il faut
aussi qu'on soit attentif à ça et aux
particularités internationales puisque
si on compare par exemple c'est pas du
tout la même les mêmes pratiques chez
nos voisins ou même aux États-Unis quand
il s'agit de d'utiliser des
antipyrétiques ou des antalgiques
alors est-ce qu'on a eu un défaut
d'anticipation
vous avez noté que nous avons traversé
tous ensemble une pandémie totalement
sans précédent
vous avez dit que c'était pas un scoop
si c'était quand même une situation
quasi inédite que d'avoir trois
épidémies en même temps je crois que ça
n'était jamais arrivé en France d'abord
parce que l'épidémie de RS est survenue
très tôt et très violentes puisque là
encore il y a peut-être un impact de la
pandémie et un impact des mesures
barrières il faut aussi rappeler le fait
que les mesures barrières ont permis
d'éviter aussi d'autres maladies virales
ou bactériennes pendant le port de ces
mesures barrières pendant la pandémie et
puis cette alignement des trois des
trois épidémies alors que nous avions
des conséquences de la pandémie sur les
productions industrielles c'est ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure notamment
sur la moticilline voilà ça a été ça a
été probablement une des raisons
de la situation extrêmement tendue qu'on
a connu notamment à l'automne
nous essayons d'anticiper au maximum
c'est d'ailleurs la volonté absolue de
la DGS que d'avoir le maximum
d'information et c'est la même chose
côté ansm il y a un vrai enjeu à ce que
l'information en amont arrive aux
autorités en ce qui concerne les les on
va dire l'anticipation par les
professionnels les professionnels nous
les avons en permanence en contact
direct et donc évidemment nous tenons
compte de toutes les de tous les signaux
qui sont émis que ce soit par des
professionnels de santé de ville ou des
professionnels de santé hospitaliers et
j'en profite quand même pour citer une
mobilisation très forte je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure des préparations
hospitalières spéciales je voudrais
quand même aussi dire un mot des
préparations qui sont faites par nos
collègues qui sont responsables des
préparations magistrales c'est quand
même aussi une des spécificités
françaises que d'avoir des officines une
quarantaine d'officine je crois que vous
avez vous avez même pu aller visiter
l'une d'entre elles ça a été extrêmement
utile alors on peut pas toujours faire
ça parce que c'est une contrainte très
particulière et un investissement très
fort des pharmaciens mais c'est quand
même une des forces je trouve de cette
crise que d'avoir mis en avant à la fois
les préparations hospitalières spéciales
je vous en parlais pour les cura mais
aussi les préparations magistrales qui
ont été faites donc par des officines de
ville qui ont permis quand même de
produire de façon tout à fait
considérable des médicaments dont les
Français avaient besoin et donc c'est un
coup de chapeau que je que je porte au
pharmacien d'officine en ce qui concerne
les conséquences et en ce qui concerne
les pertes de chances c'est deux sujets
évidemment très importants pour moi
d'abord peut-être pour rappeler et c'est
important que dans le sujet de
l'exposition aux antibiotiques vous
savez que la consommation antibiotique
est aussi très fortement reliée à la
croissance et à l'émergence et à la
diffusion des résistances donc il y a
aussi cet effet spécifique et très
particulier aux antibiotiques que
d'avoir des conséquences sur les
méchants l'émergence de résistance sur
les bactéries en ce qui concerne les
pertes de chances pour les patients
c'est un phénomène qui évidemment nous
préoccupe et qu'on essaye de monitorer
ou de mesurer mais qui est complexe à
mesurer pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que il est assez rare qui est des
absences totales de traitement il peut y
avoir eu des retards ou des besoins de
de
passer à de substituer ou de changer de
médicaments donc l'absence total est
heureusement relativement rare et la
question comme toujours en médecine
c'est l'imputabilité d'une situation sur
l'évolution du patient par contre nous
nous souhaitons évidemment que d'une
part les patients et d'autre part les
professionnels de santé nous signalent
ces pertes de chance il y a déjà eu des
travaux effectivement vous les avez vous
les avez notés ça a été fait en
particulier par un certain nombre de
sociétés savantes dans le champ du
cancer ou un certain nombre de de
partenaires d'associations de France à
60 ans aussi qui nous ont qui nous ont
beaucoup aidé sur ce plan moi je
voudrais rappeler de deux points avant
d'entrer dans des détails de
particulière ou de publications
scientifiques ces deux sujets importants
d'abord
toutes hiatrogénie tout est fait
indésirable grave en France peut être
déclaré par l'ensemble des Français je
crois qu'on est à des rares pays qui
peut faire ça nous avons un portail qui
s'appelle un portail de déclaration
portail de signalement et si une
situation grave survient dans le champ
de la santé on peut parfaitement
utiliser ce portail qui ensuite bascule
vers par exemple un centre régional de
pharmacovigilance et vers l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament donc
ça veut dire qu'en France il y a pas de
filtre et que tout citoyen tout
association peut signaler une situation
particulière nous avons mobilisé donc
sur le sur le recueil d'événements
indésirables graves
qui sont recueillis notamment dans le
champ de la pharmacovigence par l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament mais
les académies sont mobilisés l'Académie
de pharmacies en particulier il y a eu
des travaux notamment de certains CHU
français et puis il y a aussi la Ligue
contre le cancer qui a regardé si
effectivement lorsqu'il était difficile
de se fournir en certains médicaments
anticancéreux il y avait des
conséquences sur la survie du patient
donc ça fait évidemment partie de nos de
nos de nos enjeux que d'avoir en
permanence ce dispositif de suivi de
l'état de la population avec une
approche pharmacovigilance qui est
l'approche de la NSM mais aussi avec une
approche j'allais dire plus santé
publique qui peut être porté d'une part
par santé publique France sur le champ
de l'évolution de la résistance
d'antibiotiques ou par l'Institut du
cancer justement quand des maladies
chroniques et des patients atteints de
maladies chroniques et notamment de
cancer ont une difficulté de prise en
charge mais je profite du du point
antibiotique même si c'est évidemment
pas un argument pour minimiser l'impact
des tensions pour rappeler la France a
des plus gros consommateurs
d'antibiotiques je donne un exemple qui
est toujours assez frappant on consomme
presque 3 fois plus
d'antibiotiques que nos amis hollandais
or il y a pas plus de morts au Pays-Bas
il y a peut-être même un peu moins de
résistance aux antibiotiques donc ça
c'est une prise de conscience que je
souhaite de la part de nos concitoyens
c'est que les antibiotiques sont des
molécules extrêmement précieuses qui ont
un impact considérable sur notre flore
et sur les margence de résistance et que
donc c'est vraiment le le la bonne
pratique la bonne indication et la bonne
voie le bon moment le bon dosage et la
bonne personne qui doivent être
respectées puisque on a vraiment besoin
d'avoir une prescription parfaite et une
adhésion parfaite du patient à son
traitement et là je salue le rôle des
médecins prescripteurs et des
pharmaciens qui insistent beaucoup sur
éviter la lutte éviter le la résistance
en
passant des conseils à la fois aux
patients et lors de la délivrance pour
éviter l'automédication notamment du
chant antibiotique
alors soit la polémique sur les prix
effectivement vous avez posé une
question qui est particulièrement
complexe et
avec avec plusieurs aspects qui pour moi
sont utiles à rappeler d'abord sur
le les deux sujets qui ce qui se
mélangent dans le champ du du prix pour
moi
ils sont vraiment totalement distincts
il y a le premier sujet que vous avez
cité qui est est-ce qu'on a pas tiré le
prix des médicaments matures un peu trop
bas
c'était votre première question et puis
la seconde qui est un peu en miroir
c'est quel est le prix réel de
l'innovation
et donc sur ces deux questions vous le
savez la première ministre a lancé une
mission il y a quelques jours donc
évidemment on sera très attentif à
attendre des conclusions de cette
mission il se trouve que moi j'ai un
position un petit peu particulière en
tant directeur général de la Santé et
d'autre part en tant que médecin
universitaire qui continue à
m'intéresser à la littérature
scientifique
il est très difficile de savoir à quoi
correspond objectivement le prix
d'innovation ça c'est un sujet alors il
y a un article que je me permets de vous
citer qui est évidemment pas français et
pas dans une revue française donc il y a
aucun lien d'intérêt particulier c'est
un article qui est sorti dans dans le
British Medical Journal il y a quelques
jours en février et qui nous interroge
collectivement sur la construction du
prix d'innovation je trouve que c'est
une approche intéressante puisque dans
ces dans ces messages
c'est un travail de recherche qui
reprend
l'histoire des grandes entreprises
pharmaceutiques et notamment
de celles qui sont les plus mobilisées
sur la recherche et développement et qui
justement s'interroge sur le fait que
finalement
dans ce Prix de l'Innovation il y a
objectivement d'autres d'autres dépenses
que celle de la recherche et
l'innovation il peut y avoir des
dépenses qui sont réelles mais dépenses
qui sont pas forcément dans le champ de
la recherche et du développement et que
à chaque fois aussi se pose la question
mais ça vous le savez que c'est un débat
que nous avons entre expert sur les
avantages cliniques et thérapeutiques
qu'apporte l'innovation par rapport à
votre traitement existants il peut y
avoir des vrais pas des vrais ruptures
mais parfois des évolutions modestes et
puis par ailleurs il y a des innovations
qui peuvent être extrêmement
intéressantes sur le plan médical et qui
n'ont qui ne sont pas forcément très
coûteuses donc tout ça tout ça fait que
il y a une réflexion très importante
alors je crois que ce matin vous vous
entendiez le président des ceps et je
voudrais juste dire deux mots sur le
rôle que nous souhaitons nous jouer au
niveau européen parce que je pense que
la réponse
une réponse partielle sur les enjeux de
prix du médicament passe par l'Europe
nous nous sommes très impliqués sur ce
qu'on appelle le NC le ncapr c'est à
dire le
rôle des autorités compétentes
nationales dans le
l'établissement du prix vous savez que
ça fait partie des réflexions qui sont
en cours et qui sont issus notamment de
la PFE sur le fait que nous avons
encouragé très fortement le partage
d'informations au niveau européen
puisque c'était ça aussi le le risque
dans le paysage c'était que chacun avait
sa propre politique et que chacun
gardait ses informations donc comment
est-ce qu'on partage l'information
comment on partage les expériences entre
les pays de l'Union européenne
sur les initiatives de prix sur les
remboursements sur la production et les
capacités d'efforts donc ça a été de
très nombreux groupes de travail ça a
été évidemment des
des enjeux de critères adaptés de
critères partagés et la DGS soutient
très fortement la mise en œuvre d'un
règlement à la fois pour renforcer le
rôle de l'Agence européenne du
médicament et je me permets de souligner
que la directrice générale de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament un
poste très élevé et très important à
Lema et c'est très bien pour la France
donc on pèse dans cette agence
européenne qui qui est en cours de
renforcement et on est très ambitieux
pour cette agence qui a de nouvelles
capacité qui peut maintenant mieux
surveiller les pénuries qui peut mieux
intervenir en urgence dans les
événements majeurs qui peut éviter donc
les crises de santé publique en pilotant
davantage la réponse et puis vous savez
il y a cette nouvelle agence aussi de
réponse aux crises et RA
qui est directement rattaché à la
commission santé à la commissaire santé
de l'Union européenne et il se trouve
que le DGS et le DGA le DGE pardon
participe au bord de Ra donc là aussi on
pèse pour que nous ayons des moyens de
de disposer de mesure incitatives
optionnelles qui permettent à cette
agence de stimuler
l'arrivée la mise sur le marché de de
molécules notamment d'antimicrobiens
donc on est très impliqué dans ces
travaux on a aussi poussé pour que sur
une base volontaire les États membres
puissent procéder à des achats et des
négociations de prix conjoint je pense
que quand on négocie en tant que Europe
on est encore plus puissant il y a eu
des initiatives récentes je pourrais
vous les citer notamment et enfin sur la
fixation des prix qui vous savez
et n'est pas dans le champ de compétence
de l'Union européenne
on est vraiment sur là encore une
réflexion sur la cartographie commune
sur la réponse secrète sur le
renforcement du cadre de lutte et
notamment vous savez la législation
pharmaceutique européenne et sur la
place de era pour acquérir des stocks là
encore pour me mettre en situation de
crise d'avoir des capacités de réponse
et notamment dans le champ des anti
microbiens donc là encore une réponse
européenne et un engagement de la DGS à
participer vraiment de en première ligne
à cette évolution du paysage européen
alors
vous avez cité un point très important
qui est celui de du modèle français
dans le champ du des produits sanguins
la bile et des médicaments dérivés du
sang pour moi ce sont deux sujets très
différents les produits sanguins la bile
c'est un enjeu
d'autosuffisant
pour nos concitoyens c'est à dire
disposer de poches de sang
quand ils en ont besoin et vous savez
combien c'est compliqué et j'en profite
pour tirer tout de suite mon chapeau au
donneur nous avons un énorme défi en
France et que nous avons des donneurs
qui vieillissent c'est normal ils sont à
mobilisés depuis des décennies il faut
maintenant qu'on acquiert qu'on mobilise
des nouveaux donneurs il y a une grande
campagne qui est faite par le FS pour
recueillir ce nouveau donneur alors ça a
été très compliqué et c'est pas une
c'est pas une critique ça a été très
compliqué pendant la pandémie puisque
elle est donnée son sang avec toutes les
conditions que vous imaginiez en étant
négatif c'était compliqué là il y a une
vraie remobilisation des donneurs et
donc je remercie toutes celles et tous
ceux qui se mobilisent pour donner leur
sang
ça c'est la partie produit sanguin la
ville et vous savez que nous avons un
autre acteur qui est le LFB qui est
entre guillemets le client de l'EFS
puisque le FS du fournit le plasma et
que ce producteur est donc engagé dans
la production de produits totalement
différents que sont des médicaments ce
sont des médicaments dérivés du sang qui
par contre là sont dans un champ de
marché complètement mondialisé puisque
vous savez qu'elle est très gros
producteur de médicaments
dérivés du sang que ce sont par exemple
des des produits qui ont actuellement
une évolution très rapide dans le champ
des indications et dans le champ du
marché c'est le propos par exemple les
indications des immunoglobulines les
spécialités petit à petit accroissent
les indications de ces immeubles
globulines et donc là encore il y a une
mission très importante qui est menée
sur sur ce duo très particulier auquel
des Français sont attachés le duo de
l'EFS et du LFB pour d'une part
s'assurer que le modèle français est
maintenu et je crois que les Français
sont très attachés à leur modèle de
de bénévolat de volontariat qui est un
modèle tout à fait solidaire tout à fait
généreux et vraiment c'est très
important quant à quant à la question du
marché des médicaments et donc des
médicaments dérivés du sang c'était
évidemment l'un des enjeux de
concurrence européenne de concurrence
mondiale et de besoin mondiaux en
produits de santé donc on est évidemment
très attentif mais pour rassurer on
n'est pas dans l'autosuffisance des
médicaments dérivés du sang puisque là
on est dans un marché d'emblée
mondialisé et ouvert et donc quand il y
a des tensions sur les médicaments
dérivés du sang et on fait appel et
c'est par la SM on fait appel à des à
des importations si nécessaire mais là
encore une grande mission est en cours
pour renforcer le le la place de l'EFS
et le lien avec le LFB pour que les
patients vous l'avez rappelé madame la
rapporteur et accès d'une part aux
produits sanguins la Bible autant que de
besoin et puis c'est effectivement
bénéficier dans les indications qui sont
avérées de médicaments dérivés du sang
lorsqu'ils en ont besoin
oui merci Monsieur le Directeur mais si
j'ai bien compris par rapport à l'une
des questions que j'ai posée concernant
le fait que
il y avait face aux pénuries un certain
nombre pour certains patients et
notamment c'est vrai on est on a été
alerté par les associations la Ligue
contre le cancer etc je l'ai dit donc
des pertes de chances le dispositif que
vous avez mis sur pied si j'ai bien
compris mais j'aimerais avoir
une précision c'est en fait plus un
dispositif un peu d'inventaire puisque
vous dites que vous avez mis en place un
portail avec une approche à la fois de
pharmacovigilance mais aussi de santé
publique donc là on est plus dans
l'inventaire j'ai pas trop ce mot mais
en tout cas un peu pour recenser le
nombre de patients ayant
ayant eu des difficultés la Ligue contre
le cancer va plus loin puisque elle dit
que c'est une paire de chances qui peut
entraîner une vie raccourcie on n'est
pas sur donc là c'est quelque chose de
quand même un peu plus conséquent donc
est-ce que c'est c'est le seul
dispositif que vous avez mis sur sur
pied ou est-ce qu'il y a un autre
dispositif parce que là on est quand
même tout est tout interpellé ça c'est
ma question de précision et une question
que j'avais j'avais oublié parce que
effectivement vous avez parlé des
préparations magistrates et on a eu
l'occasion au tout début de notre de la
mise en route de notre commission
d'enquête de nous déplacer dans une une
pharmacie qui faisait des préparations
magistrates et on a été particulièrement
intéressé par ce qu'il ce qu'il
produisait vous avez mis en exergue le
rôle de la GEPS notamment et
effectivement je suis particulièrement
sensible alors vous avez dit aussi que
ça ne peut se faire que certaines
conditions et dans certaines la
situation mais la question qui peut nous
être posée au niveau de notre commission
d'enquête parce que on a à la fois un
travail de bilan d'évaluation mais en
même temps il faut qu'on ouvre un
certain nombre de pistes de réflexion
donc est-ce qu'il
est pas intéressant de se pencher
justement sur ces possibilités
de production de médicaments et de faire
en sorte que par exemple la GEP c'est
plus de moyens sur une liste de
médicaments
préétablis pour pouvoir être à même
effectivement dans un cadre public de
fournir des médicaments et donc
d'anticiper éventuellement des ruptures
de stock
Monsieur le Directeur et après je
passerai la parole à mes collègues ou
peut-être on fait le
ok
vous voulez poser les questions les deux
questions maintenant peut-être
Emilienne Corinne Imbert d'accord merci
à la présence très aimable et je vous
prie dans une loi de m'excuser de pas
pouvoir écouter votre réponse mais je la
lire avec beaucoup d'attention en fait
je voulais partir d'un cas concret
vaccin contre la grippe automne 2020 les
pharmaciens d'officine et je remercie de
l'hommage que vous leur avez rendu
comment des vaccins en janvier février
précommandes la pandémie arrive en mars
2020 dès le mois de juin les
laboratoires qui fabriquent qui
commercialisent les vaccins contre la
grippe disent aux pharmaciens il y aura
pas possibilité d'en commander plus nous
sommes en juin campagne de vaccination
on démarre allez on va faire début
octobre jusqu'à fin décembre janvier on
voit même cette année qu'elle est
prolongée jusqu'en mars mais à l'époque
on se remet dans le contexte
qu'elle pouvait être l'action qu'elle a
été l'action ou pas de la Direction
générale de la santé même si on sait que
les processus de fabrication des vaccins
sont complexes comment à un moment donné
on n'a pas été capable de demander au
laboratoire de produire plus de vaccins
contre la grippe sachant qu'on avait de
grandes chances d'avoir une demande plus
importante que les années et parce que
vous êtes comme vous l'avez rappelé au
titre du ministère en charge de
l'anticipation et la prévention et là on
est bien sur l'anticipation et la
prévention alors qu'il a fallu qu'au
mois de décembre on nous a dit bon ben
on vous a trouvé des vaccins
quadrivalents qui ont coûté plus cher
au pays à la fois dans les achats et
dans les remboursements voilà c'est un
très concret mais j'aimerais comprendre
sur ce point précis comment ben on n'a
pas pu faire mieux en fait merci
beaucoup et encore toutes mes excuses de
pas pouvoir Emilienne
oui merci bien sûr on est tous après la
même cas que Corinne puisque la
Commission à 14h30 vous avez reparti
répondu ou Laurence poser des questions
qui qui me tarde à mon site donc la
première partie la première question
pour qui est essentiellement sur
l'Europe et sur era pour savoir mon pire
on vient de rôle qu'a joué le bardane
dans l'avancée sur le vaccin et retard
que nous on a pris
en Europe par rapport
à la fabrication de vaccins et je
voulais savoir s'il y avait des mesures
précises qui sortaient j'allais dire
depuis la création des rats qui est une
très bonne chose on est bien tous
d'accord sur l'importance du niveau
européen et de l'EMA mais est-ce qu'on a
maintenant des orientations précises des
préconisations précises le deuxième
volet de deuxième question portée sur
mon site sur la production par la
Pharmacie centrale des hôpitaux ou du
service des armées de médicaments
qui font partie de cette qui préfère
partie vous disais tout à l'heure de
l'établissement de la liste des MITM qui
pourraient qui pourrait être revu et on
pourrait imaginer qu'on puisse avoir une
production publique de
en dehors de la dire la fabrication un
peu spécifique d'amox qui se fait dans
les pharmacies de piscine on pourrait
pourquoi pas imaginer est-ce que vous
pensez comme plus ici imaginer une
fabrication une production publique à la
fois donc de ces médicaments sur sur
liste et qui nous permettrait aussi
d'anticiper les ruptures mais aussi
d'avoir des coûts de production j'ai le
souvenir d'une indication de Linka sur
la production alors maintenant je me
souviens plus de qualité la molécule
faisait dans la famille centrale des
hôpitaux autrefois et qui coûte
maintenant sur le marché puisque les
hôpitaux l'achètent dans un laboratoire
dix fois plus cher que sur la couteau
cela coûté quand c'était la Pharmacie
centrale des hôpitaux qu'il fabriquait
donc voilà moi je serai intéressé par
l'on pense par rapport à la production
publique possible de certains
médicaments
Patricia
mais assez taquine vous avez dit que les
Français consommaient trois fois plus de
d'antibiotiques par rapport à d'autres
pays européens elle a prescription c'est
quand même les médecins qui font c'est
pas le patient qui demande à avoir un
antibiotique est-ce que les médecins
bénéficient d'une aide financière en
prescrivant plus d'antibiotiques
me permettre de compléter par quelques
questions moi qui sont un peu précises
pour les anticancéreux on se par exemple
le 5 fût le 5 Féro uracile son prix
c'est 5 à 10 % de plus en Allemagne
c'est 50 à 100% de plus dans les pays
nordiques on sait qu'on a un vrai
problème d'approvisionnement sur le 5
fûts qui est un médicament conscient
anticancéreux mais pour le coup qui a un
intérêt thérapeutique majeur donc voilà
là on voit clairement que la question du
prix du médicament est un élément
important y compris pour des traitements
qui cancéro donc le regard que vous
portez sur sur ce sujet quand même du
prix du médicament ma deuxième question
concerne les médecins les médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur et la
liste est représentée 50% des
médicaments en France ça fait beaucoup
de médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeur c'est peut-être 40% enfin en tout
cas c'est une estimation qui est pas
loin de la réalité je pense que la
révision va certainement
a mener une restriction du nombre en
tout cas où en sont les réflexions par
rapport à ce sujet parce que si 6000
produits
sous contrainte je pense que c'est un
sujet et ma troisième question concerne
la gouvernance de ce sujet là parce
qu'en fait parmi les questions qui sont
posées régulièrement revient le fait
qu'il y a de multiples interlocuteurs
vous avez d'ailleurs très bien
précisé et énumérer au début de de vos
propos avec des rôles très
complémentaires il n'empêche que on
revient souvent le fait qu'il y a un
problème de de gouvernance et d'avoir un
peu un chef de fila
identifié
parce que à l'insar de ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis avec la FDA par exemple
qui décide par exemple que pour un
certain nombre de médicaments on allonge
le délai de près le de la date de
péremption enfin tout un tas de sujets
qui font que voilà il y a une réaction
assez rapide pas en temps réel mais pas
loin quand même et c'est vrai que cette
question de l'agilité est une question
qui revient souvent et quand il y a des
problèmes conjoncturels comme ceux qu'on
traverse actuellement c'est l'agilité
qui prime sur le reste
merci je vais essayer de répondre à
toutes ces questions qui a été toutes
extrêmement pertinente et complexe
peut-être commencer par par votre vos
questions madame la présidence agilité
je suis tout à fait d'accord après quel
est le bon modèle là encore pour
connaître un peu la FDA on a aussi des
procès contre la FDA où on dit que il
mélange le soutien à la recherche le
rôle de gendarme le rôle de de
régulateur que il y a pas de barrière
oui oui non mais c'est c'est la
difficulté voilà de savoir si on scinde
on va dire les les temps du du circuit
des médicaments qui est quand même un
circuit particulièrement complexe entre
l'évaluation initiale le soutien à la
recherche le guichet innovation et puis
d'aller jusqu'à jusqu'à la vraie vie et
le suivi en Virel là encore qui est un
chef de fila qui est une animation de
politique de médicaments je crois que
c'est elle existe on n'a pas cité
d'ailleurs tous les tous les acteurs du
gouvernement mais il y a évidemment la
l'assurance maladie la DGE qui sont qui
sont impliqués on pourrait même rajouter
la DGRI et le champ le champ de
recherche donc là encore ça c'est une
décision politique mais il y a plusieurs
modèles je suis pas sûr qu'il y a un
modèle plus performant que les autres en
tout cas ça mérite d'être interrogé
sur votre question des listes je
voudrais rappeler deux points parce que
c'est deux points très importants dans
la criticité il y a la criticité
médicale et là encore on pourrait en
discuter longtemps parce que évidemment
quand on est diabétique on a besoin de
son insuline ça ne pose pas de problème
il y a des gens qui ont l'impression que
leur médicament est absolument
indispensable alors c'est peut-être pas
forcément le cas il y a la vision des
différentes sociétés des différentes
associations des patients eux-mêmes et
des prescripteurs donc là encore on peut
pas se substituer aux spécialistes et on
a évidemment mobilisé et ils ont répandu
très très favorablement toutes les
sociétés savantes qui sont évidemment
les seules à même de dire qu'aujourd'hui
en 2023 les médicaments indispensables
en cardio sont les suivants et
médicaments indispensables en pneumo on
est fraudes donc là il y a un énorme
travail on les en remercie ça devrait
être aussi une réflexion européenne
quand même un peu dans le même dans la
même culture d'ailleurs je parle de
culture exprès parce que on voit bien
que les prescriptions par exemple aux
États-Unis n'ont pas du tout les mêmes
qu'en France les médicaments
fétiches aux États-Unis c'est les
anti-inflammatoires alors qu'en France
on est plutôt réticent donc là encore il
faut tenir compte des aspects culturels
le deuxième aspect c'est la criticité
industrielle c'est à dire qu'on peut se
retrouver avec un médicament critique
mais qui ne pose aucun problème de
production aucun problème de d'accès et
donc dans ce cas là on a les deux
filtres est-ce que c'est un médicament
indispensable et est-ce qu'il est
potentiellement critique et quand je dis
critique autant interne industriel c'est
pas forcément qu'il est des produits
loin de France ou loin d'Europe c'est
par exemple que la NSM identifie que
c'est un monopole et que il y a une
seule usine et que s'il y a une seule
usine là on est problématique même si
elle est à côté de chez nous
après avoir trop de médicaments dans la
liste dans la liste des MITM je suis pas
sûr que ce soit forcément un problème
alors certes ça fait une liste
extrêmement longue mais potentiellement
comme on a des leviers face au MITM et
que en face il y a des plans de gestion
et que potentiellement il y a des stocks
etc ça permet aussi de se dire que on
est potentiellement plus actif sur ces
alors vous avez posé la question des
prix et je vais y revenir parce que
plusieurs d'entre vous ont posé cette
question et donc je vais je vais prendre
du temps pour parler des prix mais il y
a eu des questions importantes autour
notamment de de la place de cette
fameuse anticipation dans le champ de la
vaccination grippal alors là c'est
important de le dire c'est un pari le
vaccin grip saisonnier il vient de
sortir là par exemple j'ai vu ça
aujourd'hui pour la saison 2023 2024 en
fait on fait le pari de circulation des
virus grippaux de la prochaine saison
épidémie
en février parce que on regarde le les
virus circulant actuellement dans
l'hémisphère sud en imaginant que ce
seront les virus circulants dans
l'hémisphère nord à partir de l'automne
prochain parce qu'il y a un délai
incompressible de fabrication des
vaccins et qu'il faut savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on met comme sous le judo donc ça
laisse peu de temps effectivement en
pharmacie et au gouvernement pour
décider jusqu'à maintenant c'était les
pharmaciens qui commandaient
tranquillement et de façon tout à fait
responsable leur vaccin en tenant compte
de leur patientèle de du nombre de
personnes qui faisaient ce qu'il faisait
vacciner entre parenthèses j'en profite
pour dire que les Français ont
parfaitement compris l'importance de la
vaccination saisonnière contre la grippe
on a maintenant une bonne couverture
vaccinale en particulier des sujets les
plus âgés
qui ont pris le réflexe d'aller en
officine pour se faire vacciner tant
mieux il y a encore un point faible ce
sont les personnes adultes relativement
jeunes avec des pathologies chroniques
qui ont des facteurs de risque de grippe
notamment c'est pas une maladie les
femmes enceintes qui sont qui peuvent
faire des formes graves et qui ne le
savent pas forcément et donc là encore
il faut qu'on arrive à embarquer ces
populations dans dans l'adhésion à la
récession de grip alors comment ça se
passe il y a l'anticipation en 2020
c'était particulier on a eu un contrat
santé publique France de complément
d'État c'était totalement inédit et on
l'a reproduit en 2021 2022 ce qu'on peut
faire c'est évidemment se rapprocher des
des commandes des commandes on va dire
de
classique de d'officine pour essayer
d'anticiper le d'anticiper la saison
mais la grippe étant quand même un des
virus les plus mutants qu'on connaisse
on peut avoir des surprises il y a des
années 100 alors typiquement 2021 2020
2021 c'est quasiment été des années sans
grippe la probablement aussi du fait
d'une certaine compétition virale ou du
de l'efficacité des mesures barrières et
donc c'est très difficile d'anticiper
les saisons grippales mais plus on aura
d'adhésion des populations qui ont une
indication et plus on aura de vaccins
efficace et de discussion entre
l'ensemble des experts plus on essaiera
de d'anticiper au mieux les saisons à
venir mais vous avez noté que cette
année comme en 2017-2018 on a en plus eu
une épidémie étrange puisqu'on n'a pas
eu un seul pic mais on a eu deux pics
avec deux virus différents d'abord de la
grippa puis de la grippe donc vous voyez
que on peut se faire surprendre encore
par la grippe qui reste des grands
mystères viraux
vous avez parlé de
des achats et de la place des rats alors
il se trouve Kera et tout est une agence
tout à fait nouvelle à laquelle donc je
participe ainsi que mon collègue DGE
ils sont extrêmement mobilisés sur la
réaction d'urgence aux crises
et donc ils ont acheté énormément de
stocks et c'est très important ce sont
des quantités très importantes de de
fonds européens qui sont mobilisés sur
la constitution de stock j'en profite
pour vous dire que la France est un des
acteurs majeur puisqu'on a demandé c'est
la DGS même qui a été
à l'origine de cette réponse à un appel
d'offres on a demandé à bénéficier de
fonds européens pour la constitution de
stock NRBC ça tombe très bien puisque
vous savez que la France évidemment
mobilisée sur ces enjeux et par ailleurs
que la France accueille des événements
majeurs dès septembre 2023 avec la Coupe
du monde de rugby et évidemment dès
l'été 2024 avec les Jeux Olympiques donc
il faut qu'on soit évidemment le mieux
préparé possible et ses soutien
européens d'une part et le la
coordination aussi avec l'OMS d'autre
part fait que on est vraiment très
mobilisés pour que ça se passe vraiment
au mieux sur les sujets de préparation
de réponses aux crises et de stocks
dédié à des situations vraiment
d'urgence sanitaire donc voilà pour pour
et je peux évidemment compléter si vous
le souhaitez pour le 5 et fut on va
regarder de très près
je ne suis pas
informé d'une demande de modification
de prix on va regarder ça de près même
si évidemment on sait bien que le c'est
un sujet essentiellement hospitalier
puisque on est là on est sur des sujets
de d'un train GHS et donc ce sont les
acheteurs hospitaliers mais il faut
qu'on refasse un point et on vous
répondra peut-être même par écrit sur si
vous le souhaitez sur le point de cinq
effets évidemment en anticancéreux tout
à fait important alors je rebondis
ensuite sur les questions de Madame la
rapporteur qui voulait que je reprécise
mon modèle c'était surveillant
il y a plusieurs aspects il y a le IG
classique lié à un médicament que vous
avez pris et que vous n'auriez pas dû
prendre ou un médicament que parce que
substituer ou un médicament vous n'avez
pas eu et là la difficulté c'est la
présomption c'est à dire qu'est-ce que
cet événement de santé qui qui m'a
touché est lié au fait que je n'ai pas
pris de médicaments je prends un exemple
caricatural il y a une méningite pas
d'antibiotiques on décède du méningite
ça c'est un effet indésirable gravissime
avec décès ces événements remontent
systématiquement puisque ça fait partie
des déclarations de
IgG grave donc il y a un système qui est
pas dédié à l'absence de médicaments
mais il y a un système de surveillance
un des effets secondaires des
médicaments ou de la substitution ou de
l'absence du médicament dans le champ de
la pharmacovigilance d'autre part de
surveillance de l'état de santé de la
population avec des survenus
d'événements graves qui remontent
systématiquement notamment par les ARS
mais aussi vers les circuits spécialisés
que sont santé publique France d'une
part pour l'état de santé de la
population pour la dégradation de la
totalité d'une prise en charge
l'assurance maladie aussi et puis bien
entendu l'Inca puisque sur le sujet du
cancer il y a un travail qui est fait
évidemment avec la Ligue contre le
cancer pour savoir si en France les
difficultés d'accès à certains
anticancéreux font que l'espérance de
vie est modifié ou que la qualité de
prise en charge est modifié donc là
évidemment on regarde de très près et
c'est pas j'allais dire c'est pas
indispositif passif ou dans l'attente de
du recueil mais bien un sujet de de
surveillance permanente et donc si on a
si on a un signal de ce niveau là
notamment s'il est s'il est grave il est
étudié en réunion de sécurité sanitaire
après vous avez à plusieurs reprises
abordées le sujet on va dire de
préoccupations majeure de Madame la
rapporteur puisque elle avait été à
l'origine d'une proposition de loi et la
création d'un pôle public moi je trouve
que c'est une réflexion évidemment très
importante je me permets de citer le
rapport de Madame Laurence Cohen puisque
vous savez que il est assez récent et
assez complet
il y a plusieurs exemples il y a des
exemples brésiliens donc la fondation de
la DO Cruz par exemple il y a sivika aux
États-Unis mais il y a aussi des
exemples en Inde et même un exemple en
Suisse
donc tout ça nous permet de faire
avancer notre réflexion d'une part sur
le fait qu'il peut y avoir des révisions
de prix tout au long de la vie d'un
médicament ça c'est un enjeu que vous
avez cité que le modèle silica
est intéressant même s'il y a évidemment
des des questions majeures sur
l'attractivité sur l'approvisionnement
sur le traitement équitable des
laboratoires et enfin
je souhaiterais ajouter un élément
de temporalité c'est à dire qu'en fait
ce qui est efficace je pense et puis on
pourra parler de des mesures qu'on est
en train de mettre en place et que le
ministre soutient évidemment fortement
pour l'adaptation de la feuille de route
renforcement de cette feuille de route
vous avez cité des préparations extrêmes
il y a les préparations hospitalières
spéciales donc il y a deux champs très
différents le champ des officines de
chambre d'hôpital cet intérêt c'est deux
dispositifs là me paraissent
fondamentaux parce qu'il permet de
réagir vite
c'est pas du tout la même chose c'est
une espèce de situation d'urgence alors
on peut les anticiper ce que j'appelais
tout à l'heure des solutions préarmées
et on a plus qu'à appuyer sur le bouton
quand on en a besoin parce que les
préparations magistrales les pharmaciens
d'officine savent les faire parce que
les préparations hospitalières spéciales
on peut anticiper c'est un temps très
différent que celui d'une part de la
création potentielle d'un pôle public de
fabrication qui sera pour le pérenne et
d'autre part que celui de la
relocalisation d'une entreprise
c'est-à-dire que par définition avoir
une entreprise en France qui a à la fois
la matière première le principe actif et
l'ensemble de la chaîne de sécuriser ça
prend forcément plusieurs années alors
que là on est d'emblée sur une réponse
rapide et qui a été opérationnel puisque
je vous ai cité
la coordination sous l'égide à NSM
ministère de l'établissement
pharmaceutique de la PHP ils ont dans un
temps très bref recherche les matières
premières fait des contrôles
travailler sur les monographies en P8
comment comment travailler une
transposition industrielle au sein au
sein de la pharmacie hospitalière et
donc c'est ce que je vous disais ce
curare a été fabriqué élaboré sur une
base de monographie qui a été faite par
les pharmaciens de PI eux-mêmes donc
comme quoi on a vraiment une grande
qualité de nos CHU et de nos pharmaciens
de l'Hospitalier et donc en travaillant
depuis la pharmacopée américaine
validation à NSM enfin ils ont oui vous
parliez de réponse à Gilles là justement
c'est c'est un bel exemple de réponse
agile on peut on peut citer des
productions certes à PHP mais aussi du
CHU de Lille des hospices ville de Lyon
on pourrait évidemment mobiliser
pourquoi pas la PHM donc on voit bien
que sur ces grands établissements on a
une plateforme de réponse qui rentre je
pense dans ce que j'appelle moi le plan
blanc du médicament c'est-à-dire en
pratique si on doit déclencher
rapidement une production donc sur cet
aspect là réflexion évidemment pour nous
de ce que pourrait être un pôle public
de production mais tous toutes les
conditions que vous imaginez en termes
d'attractivité évidemment mais voilà
c'est c'est je pense que de disposer de
disposer de solutions déjà testées
prêtes avec des pharmaciens de signes
d'une part des formations spéciales et
d'autres parts qui sont engagés dans une
procédure de plan blanc du médicament et
qui ont anticipé le plus tôt possible
ces solutions c'est évidemment quelque
chose de fondamental j'ai pas beaucoup
parlé de l'avenir et donc je vous en dis
un mot parce que vous m'avez interrogé
sur qu'est-ce que malgré tout ce qu'on a
fait il y a encore évidemment des des
défauts et donc comment est-ce qu'on
peut améliorer les choses alors je suis
extrêmement modeste et humble la
situation est tellement complexe et
évolutive et multifactorielle qui
évidemment on n'a pas la réponse à tout
et que les réponses sont européennes et
que les enjeux sont mondiaux mais on
avance quand même avec le ministre sur
beaucoup de pistes première piste et il
les a partagé d'ailleurs il y a quelques
jours avec l'ensemble des acteurs
première piste c'est cette fameuse liste
médicament critiques sur laquelle on
doit aboutir désormais dans les dans les
prochaines semaines deuxième piste
fondamentale je pense pour les patients
et pour les professionnels comment on
renforce la communication et
l'information souvent les gens nous
disent je sais pas ce qui se passe et ça
je pense que c'est une source de stress
à la fois pour le pharmacien et pour le
patient qui est en face de lui comment
ça vous savez pas mais qu'est-ce que ça
va ça va se résoudre quand qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire donc là on a un rôle
clé du pharmacien comme toujours comment
est-ce qu'on renforce l'information des
pharmacies d'officine c'est tout le
l'enjeu des logiciels fiables des
perructures pousser de l'information
directement depuis la NSM même chose
pour les établissements de santé avec là
encore des groupes de travail qui sont
sur la participation avec la DGOS du LEM
du GEM du Conseil de l'Ordre des
pharmaciens et en associant les
fédérations de patients
alors c'est ça qui est un peu
particulier en France c'est que pour les
patients atteints de maladies chroniques
les fédérations sont très structurées et
souvent les patients sont très bien
informés parce que ils sont dans des
boucles d'informations etc pour un
patient où j'allais dire avec une
pathologie aiguë ou un événement aigu
c'est plus compliqué parce qu'il a pas
forcément cette information donc il faut
aussi que le site de la NSM soit le plus
on va dire
pédagogue et accessible au grand public
troisième axe c'est celui du plan blanc
qui est un terme nouveau dans le champ
du médicament et ça ça met en mode crise
tout ce qu'on a déjà des détaillés
devant vous c'est-à-dire à la fois la
réponse européenne de type era les
capacités de l'EMA de fin de la
cartographie des risques et de répondre
uniquement aux crises mais de façon
beaucoup plus puissante puisque
européenne et puis au niveau national la
NSM les plans de gestion des pénuries
les stocks et donc des solutions clés en
main qu'on aurait déjà testé on en a
testé quelques-unes pendant la pandémie
mais qu'on mettrait en action de façon
extrêmement efficace en mode dégradé
face à face à une crise majeure et puis
probablement et ça c'est un effet
nouveau de cette de cette saison 2022
tout à fait exceptionnelle davantage
tenir compte de la saisonnalité ça peut
paraître étrange mais on voit bien
qu'il y a des qui a des des pics de
consommation et c'est pas c'est pas une
critique dans ma bouche mais
effectivement si tout le monde a mal à
la tête et qu'on a tous la vie rose
c'est logique qu'on aille tous aller en
pharmacie chercher de quoi se de quoi se
réduire nos symptômes donc ça c'est
c'est ça fait des pics évolutifs de
consommation que les pharmaciens
décrivent très bien des moments où on
leur réclame pas du tout de médicaments
et puis trois semaines après il y a une
demande d'un seul coup qui qui peut
exploser et ça c'est difficile pour les
la chaîne des médicaments de l'anticiper
donc le producteur n'a pas anticipé donc
les grossistes répartiteurs sont en
tension et les officines se retrouvent
confrontés à des difficultés majeures
donc l'anticipation pour nous c'est
important alors anticipation par les
professionnels anticipation par les
sociétés savantes par les hôpitaux tout
ça on l'a dit mais aussi par
des signaux faibles qui sont émis par
exemple par
iqvia par Gers par un certain nombre de
de personnes qui sont en amont du
circuit
c'est pas la réponse et je tiens
vraiment à être précis quand je dis que
on a manqué dans la boxicilline c'est
pas parce que on en consomme trop je
suis quand même très conscient de ça
mais il y a une partie de la réponse qui
passe par les bonnes pratiques par les
bonnes pratiques le bon usage donc
savoir que on ne fait pas
d'automédication que c'est pas la peine
d'avoir de trop de boîtes à la maison
que c'est pas la peine non plus d'aller
se précipiter quand on entend que une
tension parce que sinon ça crée des
tensions complémentaires donc toute
cette partie de recommandation du bon
usage avec un une participation très
forte de nos collègues pharmaciens de
nos collègues prescripteurs et des
patients ça va être très important et
puis enfin un axe qui est moins dans le
champ de la DGS mais qui évidemment
important c'est tout l'axe production et
donc comment est-ce que on arrive à
mettre en place une doctrine là encore
facilitant la cartographie complète des
des capacités de production de la chaîne
de production parce que souvent on a une
anticipation très importante si on a
l'information très très en amont et
c'est ce que souhaite la NSM donc il y a
des groupes de travail tant de ces
groupes de travail il y a les
professionnels de santé bien sûr mais il
y a les associations de patients qui
sont évidemment les personnes clés pour
savoir quels sont les besoins et donc là
encore il y a un travail tout à fait
important qui est fortement mobilisé et
attendu par les ministres de la Santé
j'ai répondu sur le portail j'ai répondu
sur les EIG peut-être que je n'ai pas
suffisamment répandu sur les missions en
cours simplement vous dire donc je vous
ai parlé de la mission
donc c'est une mission IGAS IGF qui est
en cours la mission médicament vous la
connaissez elle a été lancée par la
première ministre soit des génériques il
y a aussi une mission en cours et nous
on est mobilisé je crois que le
président du CPS ou la ce matin sur la
partie santé publique donc les enjeux de
santé publique de ces génériques pour
pour éclairer on va dire
d'une lumière
accès aux soins qualité des soins et
besoins des patients les décideurs et
enfin
l'article l'article 65 du pdfss est en
cours de mise en oeuvre c'est celui qui
permet de cibler les médicaments
concernés et les engagements
d'approvisionnement qui sont associés
donc on voit bien que ce sont des sujets
extrêmement complexes que tout n'est pas
fait mais que finalement la France est
probablement à des pays les plus
structurés pour répondre aux enjeux de
pénurie avec des innovations qui nous
qui intéressent nos voisins européens et
qu'on porte en plus
pour une action européenne concertée
face aux crises je pense que si le ma
bénéficie d'une cartographie des risques
à une visibilité sur la production
européenne sur les tensions européennes
sur les commandes européennes une des
grandes particularités de la pandémie de
covid ça a été la commande sans
précédent de vaccin par l'Europe donc
c'est pas forcément ce qu'on va faire à
chaque fois puisque là on parlait d'une
situation de crise et il faut évidemment
que chaque pays puisse garder
son pouvoir régalien et sa possibilité
de de comment d'État mais ou de
politique d'État des politiques
nationales mais on voit bien que la
réponse européenne face à une crise et
la négociation européenne et la
visibilité européenne sont probablement
des sujets clés donc on pousse pour
faire évoluer la réglementation
européenne
et on espère évidemment que l'Europe
sera une des réponses assez difficultés
qui sont croissantes mais qui sont aussi
liées à
un champ de production de plus en plus
complexe avec des acteurs qui sont
mondiaux avec des marchés qui évoluent
en permanence avec des indications qui
évoluent donc on voit bien que
il va falloir qu'on soit très créatif
plus réactif et évidemment
l'anticipation pour nous est un enjeu
clé puisque on est responsable à la fois
de la qualité de la sécurité mais aussi
de l'accès au traitement en pour des
enjeux évidents de santé publique
merci merci beaucoup de
la précision de vous répondre je vais
merci Monsieur le Directeur général je
fais madame monsieur je vais donc lever
la séance et je vous remercie par
ailleurs d'apporter une réponse écrite
au questionnaire que nous allons vous
faire parvenir et puis
aborder tout sujet que que vous
souhaitez
utile en complément puisque évidemment
voilà cette commission d'enquête comme
vous propose bien que c'est voilà c'est
un sujet majeur mais c'est le sujet du
moment
qui traîne un peu
et qui montre que finalement on n'a pas
réussi encore pour l'instant à
enclencher
un système qui permette de pallier au
moins partiellement cette problématique
de la pénurie de médicaments avec pas
mal d'éléments qui nous échappent de
toute façon puisque
dans une économie et une fabrication
mondialisée évidemment la question du
médicament pour qu'on puisse reprendre
la main sur cette question et reprendre
une part de souveraineté puisque la
souveraineté sanitaire c'est
l'outil sanitaire et le médicament c'est
un outil aussi de pression diplomatique
et de dans le dans le grand concert des
nations et que donc avoir une forme
d'autonomie au moins au plan européen
nous donne aussi une forme de liberté
dans tout un tas d'autres domaines
géostratégiques donc je vais lever la
séance et puis nous nous retrouvons
demain après-midi pour une table ronde
de prescripteur et de patients merci
beaucoup merci à vous